hello everybody and welcome to my 100
subscriber special I can't believe I'm
at 100 subscribers already that is
awesome uh thank you guys for actually
subscribing to me hope you guys are
enjoying the content um so what we're
going to do today is a bit of a giveaway
but we're going to try to keep it
interesting and still make for an
interesting video uh so what we're going
to be doing is we're going to be running
around RuneScape uh for 3 hours buying
from shops in pay tolay this time and uh
basically I'm going to see how much
money I can get to 3 hours and basically
we're going to give it all the way to
the winner uh the to win all to do is be
subscribed and uh just post a comment
with your in-game name that's it again
thank you guys so much for subscribing
to me and uh we'll get this underway uh
so we'll start this timer here we'll put
it for 3 hours and the challenge is
underway so let's go okay so we're at
the General Store it's been about 30
seconds here uh so we're going to go
ahead and buy a Tinder Box and we'll go
sell it quickly hopefully we can get
about 50 gold for it okay so we are at
the G uh we tried to sell it for 64
coins so we'll just put it in for a
super low price cuz we just need to get
this sold it's not worth trying to wait
to sell it for a high price or anything
okay so yeah yeah perfect we got exactly
50 gold so we'll go back and buy some
more of these okay so what we're doing
is we're just buying the Tinder boxes
the Hammers and the chisels and then
we're just hopping worlds you can see
we're just trying to use all 50 coins we
have then we'll go back sell them all
and we might do one more run after that
uh but we'll
see and we are almost out of money here
we are just buying the last bit of the
items here so we have about five gold
left so I think we're just going to run
back to the G we're going to sell
everything off and then I think we might
do a couple more runs of this because
we're trying to get at least between 5
and 10K uh before we move on to the next
method uh we might have to do a bit more
but we'll go ahead and sell these first
okay so we are about 10 minutes in we're
at 2 hours and 49 minutes and I think
we're going to end this method here uh
because it is very slow obviously only
useful in the very beginning uh so I
think we should hopefully get up to
about 5k here and it's pretty much what
we need to move on to the next method we
need to buy a couple teleports and uh we
need to have enough starting cash but
again this is awful so we're not going
to do it for too long so we'll go ahead
and sell everything back to G okay so
everything's sold we hit collect and
yeah we got 6.5k so that should be
enough money to start the new method uh
so what we're going to do is just buy a
couple teleports and we're going to head
over to the warrior Guild okay so we
bought some teleports and uh we're just
going to fador we could have got the
games necklace but it's almost 2K and
that's a good amount of our money right
now um so we just bought the Valor
teleport going to run up uh I didn't
explain at the very beginning but
basically I can use any teleporting
method to get around RuneScape but I
have to buy it um so basically as long
as I use the money I've earned it's okay
okay so we made it to the Warriors Guild
uh and some of you may already know this
method I'm going to do because I did
make a video about it basically all
we're going to do is run from the bank
uh to the two shops here from this dude
we're going to buy all the plain pizzas
and the potato with cheeses and from the
other shop we're going to buy all the
strength potion 3es
and then we're just basically in to bank
when we're full so Shop's almost full
there and we're just going to hop worlds
and what we're just going to do is we're
going to do this till we're out of the
money go sell it and then probably go do
this some more to get some starting
cash okay so we're at about 2 hours and
33 minutes and we have successfully
spent all of our money on the uh pizzas
the potatoes and the potions um so we're
just going to go to the GE to sell it
okay so we're just selling off all the
items here um they all insta sold pretty
awesome so we'll hit the collect and and
we're at 142k so that's pretty nice and
we will continue to do this method a bit
more um because we would like to have a
bit of a larger chunk of starting cash
because a lot of the other methods do
require a bit of money to be in with uh
but we're going to invest in the gamees
necklace cuz it's much quicker to get
there and we'll just teleport to birro
ber borp
borp okay so we're about an hour 50
minutes left uh so just under two hours
we've been here for about 45 minutes
just buying the potatoes and the potions
and the pizzas uh but I think we're done
for now we're going to go try something
else out so we'll go to the G and sell
this all off okay so I think we're
actually going to DeCamp the potions
here we're doing a bit of calculation I
think they're worth more when they're
decanted four do potions so we'll just
quickly decant them all uh which is
super easy just talk to this dude down
here Bob um yeah so we'll go ahead and
sell off everything we have here I'm
predicting to get 4 400k maybe uh which
is really good for only 45 minutes
really um we'll sell off the pizzas sell
off the potatoes and and we'll hit the
collect button oh wait oh no waste we're
going to sell off the strength potion
too as well as the vials uh vials two
twins each okay so we'll collect it all
oh 668k yeah that's pretty good uh we
got about 500 and a bit K from doing
that and we're at about an hour and 47
minutes remaining okay so we just bought
some teleports and we're on our way to
catherby uh we bought a couple teleports
to Camelot a couple back to rock um
we're going to catherby to go to the
archery shop uh where we're going to buy
the arrowheads there um um you can see
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be buying the admin arrowheads
and the Rune arrowheads so we're going
to buy the Rune arrowheads down to about
50 stock and we're going to totally buy
out the admin arrowheads at about 50
stock for the Rune ones uh it starts to
not be profitable anymore um but I've
done this a little bit and it seems like
you can get about 4 500k an hour again
you kind of need a starting cash stack
to begin with uh but yeah you can see
here so we'll buy them all the way down
to 50 for the Rune arrowheads and the
adamant arrowheads we'll just totally
buy them out this a little click
intensive but again this is just more of
a challenge more than what you'd
actually like to be doing yeah so we'll
check back when we've spent all our
money okay so we're at about an hour 33
minutes and we've successfully bought
all the arrowheads we can uh so we're
just going go back to verac and sell
them
all okay so we'll sell the Rune
arrowheads didn't sell for the medium
price so we'll have to lower that a
little bit um they are in demand but not
that much I guess so we'll go ahead
lower that one bit uh so we were about
660k before and now we're at 780k so
that's pretty good we're actually only
there for about I think maybe 10 minutes
so we'll go ahead and buy some more
teleports and just repeat the process
okay we're an hour 13 minutes in and we
have spent all the money again all 780k
I think we're at before uh so once again
we'll just go ahead and sell them to the
G
again okay so we're back at the GE we're
just selling this off again uh into sold
and put the collect button and 877k so
another 125k or something we made which
is pretty nice uh but now I think we're
going to go try another method here
we're going to go buy the battle staffs
from zap's staff shop um it's a bit of a
crowded place but it's pretty nice every
battle staff you manage to buy you get
about 1K in profit um so all you have to
do is basically just run down here to
the staff shop and we'll start buying
them
out okay so we're going to actually
claim our daily battle staffs um some
might call that cheating but again the
money is just going towards you so I
don't complain too much um yeah we'll
just CLA we only have 15 battle STS and
we'll claim it and it is still from an
NPC I guess I gu well it's from a barrel
but uh it still kind of counts um so
again we'll check back when we get tired
of this or we' run out of
money okay this place is packed I'm not
even sure why people would bother we got
like an inventory we're at about an hour
and four minutes left but we got one
inventory and it is really slow you get
kicked off the game from hopping so much
uh because there's no battle staffs in
these world there's like one or two Max
uh so I think we're going to abandon
this we got a full inventory and and it
did take quite a while but still we got
the battle staffs uh from the barrel
it's about 15K and we got another 15 or
20 uh so not nothing but it is
definitely way more effort than it's
worth uh so we'll go ahead and sell
these off and I think we're going to
find another method
instead okay so next up I think we're
going to go buy some Pineapples uh to
get here you just have to go to the
Grand Tree um sorry The Gnome stronghold
run up to the Grand Tree and uh a little
bit over to the left and you'll see um
food shop and it's pretty near to a bank
and uh the guy stocks pineapples
basically just going to buy the
pineapples hop world buy the pineapples
run down Bank them uh pineapples cost 2
GP each and I think you can sell them
for about two or 300 in the grand
exchange uh so this seems decent we'll
give this a try Okay so we're at about
46 minutes left and I can say this
method sucks as well there's a ton of
people doing it I don't get why I guess
it has no requirements but it's it is
packed there are people buying the
pineapples in a lot of the world um but
whatever we did it for a bit we got 200
41 pineapples and we'll just head to the
Grand exchange and sell them off okay so
we at the Grand exchange uh we can't
even sell them for the low price so we
have to lower them even
more H we'll just leave these in here we
don't need this money so much uh so I
think what we're going to do actually is
we're going to go back to the Warriors
Guild we've done a couple different
methods and honestly I just want to get
some more money to give away uh cuz the
rest of these to be fair the the
arrowheads were pretty decent um but
every the other two methods are pretty
slow and really tedious so we'll go back
here and and we'll finish off the last
like 40 minutes or so just buying from
the Warriors Guild and yeah we'll check
back when uh the timer is pretty much up
okay so we're almost done here we're
just finishing off the last 10 seconds
or so see how much more we can get see I
think we can get like one more buy so
yeah two seconds all right and we'll buy
these pizzas and that's it all right so
we have successfully completed three
hours of buying from shops only uh so
what we're going to do is just take our
stuff that we bought go back to the
Grand exchange and we'll get our grand
total and uh yeah we'll see you in a few
minutes okay so we're at the Grand
exchange we're just selling everything
off everything is insta selling the
pineapples are sold so this is it this
is everything we've gotten in the hour
so we get 900k plus however much is here
so let's just hit that collect button
and we will learn how much money you
guys can win 1.4 mil 1.5 mil almost so
I'm pretty happy with how that went
again all you have to do is comment uh
in the comment section with your in-game
name and just be subscribed and you
could win this 1.4 mil so I'm going to
leave this video up for a couple days
let people comment and then I will do a
roulette and uh we'll give it away all
right again thank you guys so much for
subscribing to me it means a lot and I
will see you guys in the next video